all right we're getting reports that
Republican congressman Trent Franks from
Arizona's about to reside possibly over
inappropriate behavior we'll bring you
any developments when they come anyway
President Obama still has Trump on his
mind
Tuesday he spoke to the Economic Club of
Chicago where cranes call on this Greg
Huns noted a startling comparison of
Trump to air claw Huns paraphrases what
he heard President Obama say we have to
tend to this garden of democracy or else
things could fall apart quickly that's
what happened in Germany in the 1930s
which despite the democracy of the Vimal
Republic and centuries of high-level
cultural and scientific achievements
Adolf Hitler rose to dominate 60 million
people died so you got to pay attention
and vote so Nazi Germany here we come
now he said this just hours before Trump
recognized Jerusalem as Israel's capital
which makes Donald Trump a pretty weak
Nazi worse yeah the worst one ever
and after America had just decimated
Isis the worst group of fascists since
the Nazis so we aren't becoming Nazis
we're stopping Nazis but this is what
liberals do comparing adversaries to
Hitler but Obama is right if you stop
paying attention anything could happen
you could elect an inexperienced senator
from Illinois who relentlessly expands
executive power with a phone and a pen a
radical progressive just a stone's throw
from Stalinism which killed over a
hundred million people see how easy this
stupid little game is so as Obama
indulges lazy tropes he ignores the
crushing of Isis a free press that's now
louder than ever and a federal
government whose reach in size may be
shrinking for once because of course
that's what dictators do they shrink
government if that's Nazi Germany
someone slept through a history class
can we call a moratorium on Hitler
comparisons one yes okay good I will say
I thought what he said about paying
attention and voting boy that's good
that's important for Democrats
especially going into midterms so it's
important for everybody Hitler
well the thing about it is he didn't
mention Trump's name but he gave every
indication like all these guys do that
he's talking about Ron yes and when you
look at what Trump's don't you talk
about Oh smaller don't do it oh wait yes
smaller government yeah but when you
look at what Trump's doing in terms of
regulation he things like this week
taking away federal Park Lane and so
forth a lot of people get upset mm-hmm
well that's why it would have been
better if well it's better for any
president to try to pass something
through Congress because that's how our
system works that you can then have it
more enshrined in law rather than having
a pen in a phone then the next president
has also has a pen and a phone and those
things get rolled back I don't think too
many people roll back federal park lands
those places aren't safe actually I've
been told I'm not allowed in the park
all right so Jesse yeah the thing that
kills me about this conversation is that
it ignores the central truth that the
press has never been more alive because
of Trump
they were comatose under Obama because
that was their guy that was their benign
emperor so now they're shouting and
shouting isn't that a good thing
shouldn't they rejoice yeah I mean
they're all getting rich and that's fine
that's democracy and capitalism but this
is a case study and media bias
imagine if Bush oh yeah well in the
first year came out overseas and called
Obama Hitler I mean that would be a huge
story and now the press is covering up
for this you're not going to hear it
anywhere probably except here on the
five also I thought Obama was better
than this to compare his predecessor to
Adolf Hitler no no any successor the
successor to a long horrible horrible
just demeaning beneath him I thought he
was better than this I
guess it was wrong I'm not often wrong
but I guess I he's as bitter as the
bitter cleaners he smeared earlier on in
2008 and there's a reason he's so bitter
one it's because his legacy is being
dismembered limb from limb they're about
to revoke the mandate the Iran deals in
the crosshairs the year he leaves office
the economy starts surging Paris and
Isis is being decimated so I understand
why he's angry but that was just a
horrific comparison oh yeah you should
look at his numbers versus Trump's
number Sunday's if you just see this
thing
very good that's right okay gee that's a
good thing for a Trump backer this thing
talked to me in eight years never rarely
if ever wrong ninety-nine point nine he
was what he was wrong once but they
don't see what I look like in eight
years
wait when actually I think it's coming
back it was spinning a little and a lot
of bacon yeah bacon rubbing simulate the
production gets a swine shine you know
you should ask Kimberly for some of her
here yeah yes yes this is true what were
we talking about
President Obama and I said to myself
self how long would it take for him to
try to take credit for the Trump economy
because he's like Jessie very good at
saying I was right or had this I'm
responsible for this and I was living
with everyone right it's really true
he's got a let's say a healthy sense of
himself and of course he wants to take
credit for you know president Trump's
accomplishments but you know that's fine
as long as the country is going ahead
I'm fine with the results speak for
themselves